Its super late!
How I'm possibly gonna have time to make a video today?
How could I possibly spend all this time and effort
into making anything meaningful for my millions of subscribers?
Oh that's right, I'll make YOU LAUGHT YOU LOSE!
*swedish*
I'm tired, so this is gonna be hard.
This is gonna be really difficult.
The rule is simple:
Let's just jump into it.
[wtf pewds??]
"I bet you con't understand a word in this video"
[lol look at pewds]
[jesus, WHAT]
[for the people that actually need these subtitles, the people who honestly don't need them can't understand what she's saying] saying
[wtf is wrong with her?]
No more.
No more of this.
[Pewds imitates]
SKRATTARDUFORLOARDU
That's right, Jay x ∞
I'm not even trying
So pathetic.
I'm putting on my AC while I communicate.
That's right, that's so much-
I've just realized it was getting hot, and I think I got the gist of it,
he's saying "That's right Jay", although I really like Red Letter Media,
It really did make me chuckle.
I am also kind of hot.
Thank you for asking.
That should be better, now I'm more comfortable.
How are you doing? *laughs*
76 million subscribers everybody, this is as good as it gets.
It's the peak that you're getting alright.
78, that's right, Jesus Christ. [but it's 79?!]
LET'S JUST KEEP JUMPING INTO IT GUYS
Have you lost a challenge yet?
[orgasms]
I know Marzia would like this meme.
Oh that's great.
Me and Marzia have a drum set each and we play it on the switch its so fun.
That's like legit- *laughs*
An actual proper representation of what it's like to play that game.
[ww.letmesliceoffyourdick.com]
What did that fun, wonderful madame say?
www.letmeslice
Man: And I appreciate my friends.
Man: Also, my wife, and my girlfriend.. I mean my wife"
[facepalms x ∞]
Man: I mean my wife..
M: I'm so sorry, my wife, I love you so much
*laughs* Is that real? That seems fake.
Pewds: I love how he look into the camera.
[repeat]
*pewds laughs*
He looks into the camera like: UGH GODDAMMIT
JESUS IS CONFIRMED FOR SMASH
Thank you jesus
CHRISTIAN CHANNEL, very cOOl
Oh my gosh, I am freaking out right now, I'm shaking.
I'm shaking, Jesus Christ
How long can I prolong this joke to prolong this video?
Let's just keep jumping into it, okay.
What the hell is this?
What is this?
What is this??
[real terror]
*pewds laughs*
*pewds laughs again*
*and again*
What is this, huh?
Why do I always cut it?
This is the viking level goddamn beautiful
Just pure [some word I didn't get]
What is dis? Why?
[I'm not supposed to have my own opinion, but ew]
All right, I get it.
*pewds laughs* Hi, I'm Gloria Borger
from pew news
Hey, Felix! Can we get a comment from you for this article??
BYE!
What da hell was dat?
[what is the meaning of life?]
Oh!
I can't believe I laughed at that [me too]
So bad, GoD dAmN iT
You know, for once, I lose, Okay? I actually lose
The fact that I-
How many episodes has it been?
I admit defeat
I lost
I lost, god damn it
Okay, moving on. Let's just keep jumping into it guys.
Science
It's gonna be sains [science, pewds]
Just play it.
I already know what's coming.
*weird ass noises*
Jesus Chri- OOF
*mumbling*
*failed attempts to pronounce Mjolnir*
"Jonathan"
JoNaThAn
Come here, Jonathan!
By the power of [something I can't decipher]
Wait. How did you not know this??
[look at her face]
*weird laugh by poods*
I can't tell if this is set up or not.
That's so funny.
Oh, my sides. Oh, that's great.
Crucial!!
I really lost.
At this point, I don't care.
What the hell is on there?
Doesn't matter.
Oh x4
Jeez- *ends up laughing*
I have seen that one
but I forgot.
Jesus Christ
Guess some people don't like to be approached.
This is why I have social anxiety issues. [you do?]
What's gonna happen?
Nothing.
I can't believe I fell for that meme!
I fell fore that meme, guys. Gosh darn it.
Okay, then. Let's end it here. [that's what he said]
Smash like if you enjoyed.
Thank you guys, for ONE YEAR of You Laugh You Lose
Wow. It's been my pleasure, honour and privilege
for you to smash like on this video.
Hope you guys enjoyed it and it really means a lot to me
that you smash like twice on this video.
Thank you guys, so much. Love you guys, so much.
See you guys next year, so much.
And I see you guys, so much.
Goodbye, so much.